bbc says clark county is back to having
a high transmission level for the corona
virus more than five and a half million
coveted tests have been performed across
the state since the pandemic began this
morning we're going inside of a private
testing facility in henderson hector
mejia joining us there live hector
testing technology has really improved
in this short amount of time
it has and there's a new method of
testing and this one involves an oral
rinse which makes it really easy for
children joining us live we have tony
here with mdx labs he's going to quickly
walk us through the whole process and
just how unique is it good morning sir
absolutely good morning how are you
great so tell us about the whole process
here sure so quicksaw is a very very
simple method it's an oral rinse that
takes 60 seconds to administer
it's switched around in the mouth
the contents are returned to its tube
after it's done
the reagent is applied and sent back to
the lab for processing so this is a
simulation here but you were telling us
earlier that it is a pcr test so tell us
about the accuracy and how available is
it to everyone here in southern nevada
yeah absolutely so it's uh it's 99.999
percent accurate
it's ran on the thermo fisher quan
studios it's a pcr test
we have three locations in the valley
we've done over a hundred thousand pcr
tests
with zero out-of-pocket costs to the
community so so even if someone doesn't
have insurance you guys are still able
to work with them and provide it without
a charge absolutely the cares that
covers it we've never charged anybody a
dollar out of pocket since we've been
started and you're saying it's really
unique for you guys you guys are the
only ones with this technology correct
yes quicksaw is proprietary to us
and who is this ideal for you know a lot
of people are not comfortable with the
nasal swab or the oral swab you were
telling me it's really easy for children
also for the elderly absolutely we've
tested children as young as three years
old obviously and you know
senior citizens nobody likes getting a
q-tip jammed up their nose so this is
definitely a friendlier method and more
comfortable for everyone awesome thank
you for your time and for that
demonstration we'll have another up
close look at the operations here and
how they help not only local agencies
but also businesses with the testing
still ahead in the next half hour for
now reporting live hector mejia live
local now great to have that here in our
state hector thank you